hey youtubers is Charlie so the first
part of the Doctor Who finale just aired
we finally found out who Missy was big
WTF we learned all about the Cybermen we
have a pretty good idea of what's going
on but there's still a big mystery as to
what the doctor is going to do about it
the biggest things we needed to talk
about are the Missy reveal and what it
means for the future of that character
so many crazy things were going on it
feels like the doctor was the only one
with his head on straight in this
episode normally it's the other way
around normally he's the madman in the
box quick reminder new round of the
giveaway starts right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so careful
for spoilers from the first part of the
finale if you haven't seen it yet but
starting with top 5 moments ok everybody
ready here we go number 5 Danny pink is
dead what a heartbreaking way to begin
the finale
especially that whole montage with Clara
it's hard to tell how much time it
passed but they hadn't cremated Danny's
remains so it couldn't have been that
long
I bet less than a day had passed when
she started to phone the doctor I didn't
recognize the planet the TARDIS was
parked on so if you do know what that is
just write it below in the comments I
feel like they tried extra hard to go to
some more alien places in series 8 Matt
Smith came to America Peter Capaldi's
going everywhere he can in outer space I
know there were a lot of early evil
Clara theories so whenever she said I am
owed better to her grandmother I felt
like that was starting to tease some
sort of evil Clara montage which leads
me to number 4 Clara tries to pull a
fast one on Malcolm Tucker and just fair
warning I'm gonna cuss a little bit
because Malcolm Tucker you understand
little did Clara know that the doctor is
completely unfuckable
he has never been before as far
as we know maybe River Song would have
something to say about that definitely
loud flashing warning lights all over
the place whenever the doctor woke up in
the volcano giant shout-out to fires of
Pompeii there were a lot of theories
that they would go back to Pompeii
I don't know necessarily that that's
where they were but I feel like that's
why they went to an active volcano like
it was just a big wink to that everybody
let me know how you feel about Clara in
this moment I felt like after this scene
everyone would be totally okay with
Claude not coming back everyone would be
like okay fine
you completely tried to screw the doctor
this is what you get I did feel a little
slapped in the face when the doctor said
that none of that mattered you betrayed
me you betrayed our trust still I don't
care
he's setting himself up to be royally
screwed even if Clark's not the one to
do it
it did lighten the mood but I do wonder
if the doctor has another way besides
the keys to get inside the TARDIS I
understand the need to do crazy things
to try and surprise the audience
especially in a season when there's been
so many spoilers about Doctor Who
stories but I'm not a huge fan of when
they completely take everything back
after scene it feels a little
disingenuous like if they were going to
have car through all the TARDIS keys in
the volcano I feel like they should have
left it that way and the doctor should
have had another way back in the TARDIS
he still could have forgiven her but
that whole scene feels like a wasted
moment when they say something never
even happened why bother writing that
scene and spending the time to film it
when you could have filmed another scene
I feel like that car scene is gonna be
one of the most controversial from
Clara's run pending anything she does in
the last episode I do have to hand it to
Moffat for having the balls to try
something like that I can feel half the
Phantom rising up in rage at the moment
car owned up to it and said yeah I did
that I love him it makes me feel like
she's definitely not coming back
like he just lends more credence to the
idea that Clara is completely done with
the doctor the doctor is just a tool to
get what she wants now so their
relationship is completely broken
regardless of what the doctor says
number three
welcome to the nethersphere so we
finally get to see what everyone's been
seeing whenever they look at those
windows jumping forward a bit we found
out that what Danny pink is seeing is
the inside of the matrix his
consciousness was uploaded to the matrix
so it's not an actual physical place
it's like cyberspace Sep said that he
was in a new body but really that's not
true but he is still connected to his
physical body like his consciousness is
they kind of explained the 3w
Association don't cremate my body don't
cremate my body don't cremate my body
just to explain the cremation thing they
can't use their skeleton to create a
Cyberman if they're cremated the whole
3w think felt like a riff on the beating
of drums even though that was a four
beat I did love the Welcome that Missy
gave the doctor it doesn't completely
explain the relationship between the
master and the doctor because I don't
think there was anything sexual between
them before Time Lords get new
personality traits when they regenerates
so I guess you could look at that is the
explanation for why Missy is calling the
doctor her boyfriend it's a bit weird I
hope they explained it in the second
part of the finale the Time Lord
technology she's using the matrix is the
nethersphere and I think that was Missy
pretending to be a robot that was the
actual Missy it was just the master
having fun with the doctor number two
the dead have been cyber converted
previously the Cybermen have not been
able to do this I feel like it's only
because the master is using Time Lord
technology to bridge that gap that's why
he's able to upload the mind upgrade the
body so to speak I'm getting a little
confused talking about Missy in the
master so I hope you guys all understand
I'm probably going to be jumping back
and forth between pronouns without
realizing it right now pretty much just
thinking about the Cybermen is the
toclafane just another way to take over
the earth the big question now is why is
the master so obsessed with earth he can
go anywhere he wants in time and space
presumably I think he's just trying to
get at the doctor the doctor loves earth
so the master wants to break his toy the
Cybermen invasion itself you know
marching down the steps the st. Paul's
Cathedral is a big call back to a second
doctor episode that time it was like the
last big episode the Cybermen were in
for a long long time so it's a really
notable callback to Doctor Who history
as well as just a really big thing to
show you know Cybermen marching through
modern-day London I like that no one is
flipping out looking around pay no
attention to the crazy Scotsman I didn't
know match was on you think the people
would flip out more maybe they just
think it's a flash mob there was that
moment during the last episode for the
doctor kind of remarks about how
children weren't surprised by anything
like a big force grew up and they didn't
think it was a big deal maybe this is
just a callback to that people just
don't think a bunch of Cybermen walking
around or a big deal and my number one
WTF moment of course Missy is the
mistress so many questions right now how
did he survive the end of time and what
does this mean for the future that
character right off the bat I don't
think that he's going to die at the end
of this there's no way they're going to
kill the master character off they keep
bringing him back he'll find a way to
escape or she'll find a way to escape
but for all intents and purposes during
Capaldi's run through series nine or
however long he stays Michelle Gomez
will be playing this character I don't
think they're going to gender swap her
again I know everyone totally loved the
Johnson master but he has that show on
BBC America intruders so there's just no
way he could play the character again
maybe he could cameo in a background
shot or something like that that would
be pretty funny
of all the people Missy could have
turned out to be I feel like this was at
or near the top of everyone's list there
are at least three people I feel like
everyone thought she could have been the
craziest being a splinter version of
Clara which was why everyone was going
crazy with the car WTF moments from the
finale trailer then there was a female
version of the master and then there was
the Rani two out of three are time
ladies I do like that Missy said time
lady it's been a long time since we've
seen one on the show so I am glad that
one's back with a bit of a twist just in
terms of the future of the character I
think that after we get through this
finale we're not just going to keep
seeing her come back all the time even
at the end of series 3 and series 4 we
didn't see him in that many episodes so
we should all start thinking about how
she is going to escape at the end let me
know though what was your favorite
moment from the episode and let me know
how do you feel about the Missy mistress
reveal why you guys think about that
here are some of the Easter eggs I
spotted so first up obviously it was the
fires of Pompeii which I mentioned
active volcano very dangerous one of the
only ways to destroy a TARDIS key then
there's the matrix the last time we saw
that was actually in a valued episode
during that episode the master took
control of the matrix and obtained the
key of Rassilon I don't know if they'll
explain it but at the time that was the
only way to get inside the matrix was to
have the key of Rassilon
hopefully they'll explain that in the
second part of the finale I know there
were some theories about Missy being a
version of the value so this is about as
close as you're going to get when we saw
the shot of the afterlife it looked a
lot like Pete's world the alternate
reality where the cybus industries
Cybermen were created it just felt like
a visual reference to that the psychic
paper was probably one of the funniest
Easter eggs while thus wearing just a
giant shout out to Malcolm Tucker and
like I said the three w's felt like a
bit of a reference to the beating of
drums that was a fundamental part of the
character the beating of drums so it's
unclear whether or not now that he's
regenerated into a woman that they're
gonna continue doing that if you spotted
any other Easter eggs in the episode
that I didn't list just write them below
in the comments all in all I'll give the
finale a solid a four just huge WTF
reveals Moffat totally has some stones
on him to turn the master into a
mistress what the episode did really
well was deliver on excitement first off
you have a companion completely
betraying the doctor huge WTF I can't
remember the last time a companion went
that crazy River
as a companion kind of but she was evil
before she became a companion I did feel
like Jenna Coleman's evil performance
was probably one of the better ones that
she's turned in so I'll give a hat tip
to her for that MARY POPPINS hats off to
Michelle Gomez - for her performance
playing the master is just like playing
the doctor there been so many people to
do it before you you have to find a way
to make it your own while at the same
time keeping a lot of familiar things
about the character the master is kind
of like an evil mirror of the doctor
that same crazy mad man in a box thing
or mad woman in a box this episode was
mostly her dancing around the doctor
just having fun so I'll be interested to
see if she goes full evil in the second
half crazy master is a lot of fun but I
like playful master a lot better so
hopefully she'll keep it under a hat
just a little bit when it's all said and
done I'm hoping we get to see her in the
Christmas special at least in some way
all the people that are theorizing about
Jenna Coleman leaving I feel like that
is when the transition would be made so
just a quick reminder Q&A posting
tomorrow so be sure to subscribe to get
that post all your questions in the
comments I'm totally bummed the Doctor
Who is ending so soon but it's really
only a couple weeks before the Christmas
special like it's not going to be that
long for those asking I will be doing
more Sherlock series for videos whenever
Doctor Who is done they will be filming
that Christmas special the 2015
Christmas special in January so while
you keep thinking about the big WTF
Missy reveal you can click here for the
Q&A I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it and click here for my Doctor Who
episode 10 video thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five and I
will see you guys tonight
you